I think back one of the um viral moments
when in the blog area that you had was
when you know in my opinion one of the
greatest rappers of all time fell death
to your sword on stage and I'm talking
about Royce the five nine love was you
guys had a battle and
I think Royce is one of the greatest of
all time um
bodied him it was rough no it was
because I felt like you caught him off
guard and there was a lot more factors
into what happened right right it wasn't
like Royce got killed but like the
circumstances did not line up favorably
for Royce he was caught off guard a
little bit I also don't think Royce came
there like
I mean you could kind of give me a
little background what happened that
night because it's on YouTube right and
not a lot of people can say
I shot the Fate on stage with Royce and
rapping and I got him right
um I caught him on guard that night I
don't think that he knew
um
competitively what we were supposed to
do that night okay
um I think one thing that was told to me
was we're gonna have a freestyle battle
with this person this person this person
and everybody's going to be there
um one guy didn't show up
um I think something happened to
something something did happen to Joe
Budden's brother that night so Joe was
supposed to be there right and and this
is why I tell people all the time here's
uh here's a good hairline headline for
us
that night created slaughterhouse
um
because Joe Button was supposed to
perform that night unfortunately
something had happened to his brother
which prevented him from coming which
left me and Royce to battle and duel so
when we got up there to battle I don't
think that he understood that it was
like that kind of battle like it's more
like everybody just just get a versa
so I caught him off guard
um
me being the young you know
super guy just
excited you know for one him being one
of my favorite rappers he's a goat to
being like yo I get a chance to spar
with
with Royce tonight yeah I'm bringing the
best shot I'm going I'm swinging so you
know what I'm saying so
um we did that so then that led to Joe
and Royce having words
I forgot they had the little beef yeah
this is before slaughterhouse like so
that night created slaughterhouse yeah
because off of their beef is how they
kind of yeah cool so then it was like
Joe was like
you Royce y'all whack whoa whoa you know
Joe Joe gets in his bag and he was like
whatever like you're not even in my lone
lane and then Joe and Royce
I mean uh uh Joe and Royce and then me
and Royce and they were like
we did what we did
and then they were they went and then
they
you know that was uh that began until I
kicked off that whole wave of event for
real so it conflated they came together
they got Joel and and uh and crooked and
created who was on that first song Nino
bless was on a song with them and he was
like there was there was a song called
slaughterhouse and I think it was five
of them but they didn't end up including
Nino blessed so j-o crook yeah and Joe
and then they created you know arguably
one of the dopest groups you know
especially the first album was amazing
for sure man to be able to watch all of
those dudes just trade bars this is
super dope man it was funny because my
dude came to me one day he was like cuz
man you helped spark that bro they could
at least put you on a song or something
bro I say man that's crazy I say man
they in a different League man you know
we we the underground we like the dudes
that beat Tyson in prison and nobody
knows his name we just heard the rumors
of Tyson lost a fight in jail what is
interesting too because I do feel like
uh for whatever reason it's still
happening but in terms of like
the Bay Area if you go to the Bay it is
very much like its own
like you're like in your own country
kind of for sure pop it's like an island
like you go to the club you're gonna
hear you're gonna hear songs from
people who aren't from the bay that you
won't hear anywhere else
like you'll hear some baby boy the
prince or something like for sure you'll
just hear that like only worked
there the way we live still gets play
and that's what I mean like they're like
that way that record I think one of the
young guys just redid that beat or
something or he's planning to redo that
beat that record is still big and people
like never even heard that record it's
so crazy because like it is indeed its
own Island and I think that there's like
gifts and curses with that while also
being like one of the most influential
places in hip-hop
there's so many things you can trace
back to the Bay Area right
um why do you think
you know 20 years later now you you have
a lot of context to your career and and
and just you know observing the music
industry that the bass still somehow
doesn't get the flowers or respect you
think it deserves because I think it
deserves a lot more love and respect you
know in terms of of the landscape of
hip-hop you look at Independent Artists
that have dealt with
mainstream artists that have been backed
by Powerhouse machines and
you can't
there's no equivalence to an independent
artist pushing out his own product
versus a label that's pushing millions
and correct and you know I'm saying
hundreds of thousand dollars behind a
single correct for someone who's pushing
a couple pennies towards a project you
know um and and that's at the end of the
day that's what it is like the
difference is as Independent Artists
we've created an infrastructure that has
solely been based off a friend a fan
artist type relationship
um we look at what La Russell is doing
right now killing it and that's all just
fan base that's awesome he's building a
community this whole community and this
ecosystem is that's what
um to marginalize the Bay Area in a
nutshell that's what it is it's just
artists that have succeeded in respected
markets with the art with with the fans
and the group of people that support
them and they just focus on them like
you may take the hottest artists in the
country
um and put him against somebody in the
bay
that that may be thriving there
demographically and they do a show
they're going to be people that are
going to be going to that to that base
to that artist from the base record or
if they put them on the same show that
artist's gonna be like damn why y'all
let me open like someone just brought
Dilo out like a few months ago and it
was crazy it was at YG was it white I
feel like it was like somebody else YG
kailani it was maybe it was kehlani did
Kaylani yeah yeah yeah yeah okay Lonnie
brought him out
um about three months ago yeah I think
that's what I was yeah I remember seeing
that before I'm like this is a r b show
I mean obviously shoes from the bay you
know so a little little but but I was
just like that's so tight she brought
him out and then YG brought him out
about a month ago same energy
um D-Lo has hit the ground running he
just you know came home from prison and
just been hitting the ground running and
like I told him
he's so influential he doesn't even know
right he was a kid when that record was
probably 16 years old 17 years old and
all of these years later that record is
still
the number one records in the in the
party starting record sure and so now
this is about him getting out and
expanding and continuing to keep moving
forward but um you see that uh time's
over in the bay there's so many
different artists that are doing there's
a young artist named Cato who has a
record called go off that went viral on
Tick Tock and you don't see people
working records anymore and like I was
telling him though put some y'all never
even worked that record right I'm like
call this person some energy behind it
yeah put some energy behind it like if
you really put some energy behind this
record say I didn't watch y'all below 20
30 000 and on the weekend in the club or
something go put that behind somebody
call you know this guy and say man can
you work this record help me get this
record yeah I see like the stuntman kid
has been working his record for two
years two years now two years and
Thunderman his energy alone he's just a
good person great kid he's got his he's
got an amazing line of organic juices
that taste amazing he's just a great kid
great his energy for sure like his
energy is just he's just a great kid man
so